am Freitag wird im
Verteidigungsministerium in Wien ein
weiteres Kontingent für den
Auslandseinsatz dem afrikanischen mal
die verabschiedet im Rahmen der EU
Trainingsmissionen entsendet Österreich
Soldaten des Jagdkommandos der
Militärpolizei und des Jägerbataillons
25 das mit Brigadier Christian Riener
Österreich zum zweiten Mal den Mission
Force Commander stellt ist für
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Tanner
ein Beweis für die erfolgreiche Arbeit
der Österreicher in Mali
gegeben ist weil die Sahelzone ist
letztendlich eine sehr entscheidende
[Musik]
wir gehen zu können sie sprechen her
Südafrika an und neue neue Varianten
ohne Zweifel haben wir für die sichert
unsere Soldaten auch in dieser Hinsicht
dazu sorgen aber auch abgesehen vom
Virus gilt es natürlich laufend die Lage
in Mali und in den in diesem Einsatz
warm up zu beobachten das haben wir auch
beim letzten Verteidigungsminister
Rechnungshof besprochen und danach dann
einfacher Entscheidungen zu treffen zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt steht da einer
erfolgreichen Mission unsere Soldaten
nichts entgegen und an dieser Stelle für
soldatenglück an alle die Halter dann in
den Einsatz gehen